well hello there reject nation we're
gonna watch today from cosmic wonder
spider-man no way home post-credits
scene possibly reveal now's your chance
to earn some real street cred here the
movie comes out and this is the post
post-credits warren
you didn't call me back last night i
called you i left you what i think is my
top 10 voicemails of all time and yet
didn't even hear how come we don't even
talk no more
b12
[Music]
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk about the mcu and recently about
spider-man a lot and today we have to
talk about a lot a lot a lot home post
credit scene what it could be we
actually got a little bit of a hint and
at least one of the post-credits scenes
will actually tie into some other things
that have been happening within the mcu
now and we also have to talk about it
home photos which of course i'll break
down everything in this video so this is
rather interesting there was a reddit
user that went by the name my time to
shine hello that had recently leaked a
lot of accurate information about
spiderman no way home a lot of this
information was confirmed to be true
when the first trailer came out so this
person's track record for leaks in
regards to spider-man no way home is
outstanding and recently they made a
twitter account now at first we
questioned whether this was actually the
real person or not but this person went
on reddit and confirmed that it is
indeed the same person and this person
posted a few days ago halloween scoop
for y'all remember it well i'll go back
to it when no way home is released tom
holland's peter parker will get the
black symbiote suit in the mcu after no
way home now obviously that's what i
like to hear
some venom and we're talking about the
venom post credit scene because the
movie has been out for in the mc you've
seen it or at least heard about it by
now the venom let there be carnage post
credit scene pretty much does back up
this report however it adds a little bit
more to the post credit scene oh my god
okay my mind started spiraling with
possible movie ideas of where they could
go because they have to nail down the
negative influence that occurs with the
black symbiote suit attached to peter
parker how it starts to affect his life
in like some positive ways makes him
stand up for himself makes him a little
bit more confident makes him a little
bit more tough but then of course you
start to see the negative repercussions
of attitude isolation all that jazz so
i'm starting to wonder what if because
you see how venom
and eddie brock have this on again off
again bromance thing going on borderline
actual homosexual romance thing going on
what if venom decides to attach himself
to peter parker instead and then you're
starting to see like eddie brock
resenting peter because of the fact that
he no longer has his venom with him
which would then make for a personal
vendetta between the two it's like venom
had an affair with peter parker with the
younger sexier spider guy yeah the
younger sexier come photographer think
about it it's great we know that venom
is now in the mcu that's pretty much
what we know the rest of it is very
confusing whether morbius and everybody
else is over in the mcu now or whether
it's just venom but we know that venom
and eddie brock are now in the mcu and
the post-credits scene came after tom
hardy said that he's going to do
everything that he can to get venom and
spider-man to go up against each other
that combined with venom licking tom
holland spider-man through a tv screen
probably means that whatever
no way home is going to involve venom
and it won't just be spider-man vs venom
somehow spider-man is going to wear the
black venom symbiote or somehow get
another black symbiote which i think
would actually be kind of cool because
essentially you would have spider-man
venom versus regular venom but here's
the thing i asked around to other
insiders about what this could possibly
mean and each one of them told me that
they pretty much believe it is going to
be the post-credits scene for spider-man
no way home at least one of the
post-credits scenes because i do believe
that they will do some type of
post-credit for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness then of course i
do one for doctor strange multiverse and
madness i don't actually think venom is
going to be in the mcu there's two camps
here i'm under the one camp that
actually thinks this is all a big ploy
to keep spider-man actually in sony's
marvel whatever the hell they call it at
the time when it occurred keep him over
there i feel like venom's merely dipping
his toe in the mcu right now only to
whip him back into just the sony
respective universe that they have i
know that might hurt to hear for some
people but i'd say i do think that's
what's actually occurring because this
this feels like this is the sony
cinematic universe galore of what this
spider-man movie is turning out to be
featuring dr strange
yeah
and it seems like it would be a little
much to bring venom fully into the
universe because then you'd have a bunch
of other sony characters grappling for
that the most i expect of an mcu venom
appearance right now is maybe in no way
home for some particular reason and then
yeah going right back over to sony
because as you see with morbius with all
the worlds colliding there from all the
different spider-man stuff they want to
have a spider-man world not just
spider-man villains but a spider-man
world to themselves for the longest time
there's been a very interesting theory
that spider-man knowing home could
perhaps introduce the fantastic four
because of that huge avengers tower
being renovated
about building yet a lot of people
thought that it was going to go on to be
oscorp but since we got the morbius
trailer yesterday and they showed us a
new oscorp building i'm starting to
doubt that oscorp is actually going to
be in the mcu after all the green goblin
that is going to be in no way home isn't
going to be from the mcu he's going to
be from the sam raimi universe perhaps
in our universe norman osborne decided
to do something else with his life see i
feel like this whole thing with the
oscar building and the fact that they're
using a green goblin from a prior just
sony movie that was an association with
marvel and not our own specific norman
osborne that's one of spider-man's
biggest villains ever it's his joker in
a lot of ways and they're not going to
introduce the fantastic four and just to
stop it's getting
all right you want to already jam pack
your movie and then distract everybody
with jam packing it more yeah don't
don't do it or maybe it'll say baxter
building that's about as far as it'll go
but it's not going to be not going to
introduce the fantastic four although
the director of this movie is doing a
fantastic part so there is something to
this
that does have you actually kind of gone
well there could be an easter egg that's
definitely alluding to that maybe one of
them will be at least
really obviously hinted at in a post
credits sure like that but hear me out
for a second what if the fantastic four
go into space because that's what they
do and somehow they bring back a
symbiote from there perhaps peter parker
gets involved with the fantastic four in
some way shape or form we don't really
know what's going to happen in
spider-man no way home whether people
are going to know that peter parker is
spider-man by the end of the film but
perhaps the fantastic four do know about
spider-man and perhaps they know that
peter parker is somewhat of a genius and
somehow they team up maybe through an
internship or maybe through a job this
could lead to peter parker getting very
close and coming in contact with the
symbiote again i kind of like this one
it introduces the fantastic four
obviously and we see the fantastic four
interact with spider-man but two it
would be a different symbiote than the
actual venom symbiote look man you just
pitched the problem with amazing
spider-man
you already have your three spider-man
here along with the sinister five and
then what they fight then and then they
got oh symbiote in space we gotta go
deal with that right now yeah yeah once
he just gets the sinister five that's
like halfway through the movie and then
he goes and gets an internship just when
you think the movie's wrapping up they
go hey we got a new threat now we gotta
go to venom space it's not gonna happen
now if you had called me back
i will be all in support of this don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me
dude you really messed up warren
hey we're warren thanks for being you
you sexy beast all right guys well what
do you think the post-credits scene is
going to be leave your thoughts down
below you could also subscribe to john's
personal channel where him and his
sister
are showing you guys a
fashion try on haul types of videos
that's right it's always montages
sister comes out trying to get ready for
an event and john sits there in his
business too
no shh and then he finds the right one
at the end that's it that's it
so looking good toots
so you talk to your sister
creepy all right guys hey let's do a pic
tyler hague
miss you
that's all i want to say
i miss you tyler it's thanksgiving
season and i'm grateful for you
and all you've done i want you to know
though
i am getting a ps5 you did
provide me a ps4 a couple years ago and
i've
used it so much but
i don't know if i'm ready to move on
because if i move on from the ps4 that
means
it feels like i'm moving on from you i
don't know if i could do that
tyler i'm not ready to let you go man
you've been so good to me
and
i just
sorry
i just
here's why you know
that's
hey world man
let her know i piss on you if you want
me to man
he will piss on you
and that's
called actressing
[Music]